cathy un discours émotif frisant la
colère volodymyr zielinski ne s'est pas
remis de ce qu'il a vu la veille à abuja
pointant du doigt les troupes russes il
décrit au conseil de sécurité les
atrocités les massacres dont il a été
témoin
ils les ont mutilé égorgés ou des femmes
ont été violées devant leurs enfants
mais il n'ya pas que butch ajoutent ils
il y à épines et plusieurs autres villes
ukrainiennes
des propos appuyés par une vidéo aux
images insoutenables
puis se tournant vers le conseil de
sécurité
êtes vous prêt à fermer les nations
unies lance-t-il les lois
internationales sont elles dépassées si
vous répondez non alors il faut agir
immédiatement
les nations unies doivent être réformées
ajoutent ils le droit de veto ne donne
pas le droit de tuer le match aux fans
un show l'onu a déjà lancé sa propre
enquête however
n'oublierai jamais ces images abuja
affirme sécrétaire général antonio
guterres s il faut une imputabilité bio
touche tout ceci est une vaste mise en
scène lance l'ambassadeur russe aux
nations unies aucun civil n'a été tué à
bout de chat par les troupes russes oui
n'agissons pas comme les américains en
irak et en syrie dit-il qui ont rasé des
villes entières sans pitié nous avons
pitié du peuple ukrainien qui est proche
de nous oui ce comme ministre des
affaires étrangères russe sergueï lavrov
va plus loin en affirmant que cette
vidéo a pour but de faire dérailler les
négociations entre kiev et moscou come
back and roll et ce
toujours est il que plusieurs enquêtes
sont en cours dont celles de
l'organisation human rights watch
c'est qu'une enquête doit être
impartiale parce qu' une enquête dont
l'intégrité est temps et en doute
personne n'a besoin d'une carte d'une
enquête comme ça elle affirme que
l'organisation enquête également sur des
violations du côté des troupes aux
ukrainiennes on a vérifié à une vidéo
qui montre comment les soldats les
soldats de craignant ont tiré sur les
jambes des
des prisonniers de guerre
nous sommes témoins de la plus grande
menace à la paix et à la sécurité en
europe et dans le monde dit-il en mai 42
ans dé carrière militaire
washington il n'y a aucun doute les
responsables doivent faire face à la
cour pénale internationale pour crimes
de guerre
les etats-unis ne sont pas membres de la
cour internationale rappelle cet ancien
ambassadeur américain en union
soviétique et donc ne permettent pas à
ses citoyens d'être jugé
c'est hypocrite ajoutent-ils de dire que
d'autres pays devraient le faire
en attendant la russie fait face à de
nouvelles sanctions économiques la
commission européenne a déjà annoncé
qu'elle allait cesser toutes
importations de charbon russe qui
constituent 40 5 % de ses importations
et ici la maison blanche va annoncer
d'autres sanctions économiques dès
demain si elle boit de l'énergie sera du
canada à washington